be preaching here at battelle chapel
where I spend so many sundays during my
undergraduate days in the late 1960s and
today as you know is all saints day when
the dead are figured Lee raised in the
tradition of Lazarus and I want in
particular to honor a man whom I'd
consider a modern-day Saint my
university chaplain and pastor during
those years William Sloane coffin jr. he
was a giant physically intellectually
spiritually and it was impossible not to
notice him and be affected by him no
matter who you were coming to Yale as a
self-proclaimed atheist I took a life
changing course with him in my freshman
year called a seminar for friendly
disbelievers learned about deep
religious confrontation with racism and
war in my sophomore and junior years and
then by senior year was a deacon here in
battelle Chapel it was coffins
inspiration that led me after divinity
and law schools to develop a legal
ministry for low-income residents in a
Boston neighborhood and the refrain that
I have remembered throughout my career
was Bill coffins justice not charity and
it's a topic on which I want to speak
today in terms of prophetic envisioning
of a new earth especially in terms of
the scandal of homelessness in America
Bill coffin called us to task in these
words many of us are eager to respond to
injustice as long as we can do so
without having to confront the causes of
that's the great pitfall of charity
handouts to needy individuals are
genuine necessary responses to injustice
but they do not necessarily face the
reason for injustice I started
practicing law at a time when there was
virtually no homelessness in America in
Boston anywhere in the nation I was
actually practicing housing law spending
a lot of time dealing with slumlords
with very difficult conditions that
people were living in but it was a very
different environment with very little
homelessness and then a political
decision was made in the early 1980s
part of a tax cutting regime to reduce
the federal housing budget from 33
billion dollars annually to seven
billion dollars and this was accompanied
by decisions made nationwide to d
institutionalize mental patients in
state hospitals without fulfilling the
promise that was made to them to fund
community mental health centers for
housing and a lot of mentally ill people
were simply discharged to the streets as
direct result of these two types of
political decisions now largely
forgotten it seems and never directly
experienced by this generation of
college students many people began going
homeless in Boston and all over America
forced to sleep in subways and parks on
heating grates strangely this was
happening at the same time as new
governmental incentives were being
implemented for business along with
general tax reductions helping fuel and
economic boom which resulted in enormous
increases in wealth for the already well
to do but not for the poor who lost
ground in the 1980s churches and other
charitable institutions were asked to
step in and provide shelters
and food pantries and help the homeless
and hungry at dramatic new levels
coffins response was that and I quote
the churches have to feed the hungry
clothe the naked and shelter the
homeless but they also have to remember
that the answer to homelessness is homes
not shelters when the poor and down
truck the poor and downtrodden need is
not piecemeal charity but wholesale
justice he taught that the homeless need
political action and structural changes
in society not just a warm bed and a
warm meal in a church basement quoting
him just to the slave just as to the to
the slave freedom was not a gift but the
restoration of a right no one had any
business taking from them so a home is a
right the homeless are being robbed
ironically when the rich take from the
poor it's called an economic plan when
the poor take from the rich it's called
class warfare coffin recalled that mr.
conservative Senator Robert Taft in the
1940s considered affordable housing a
moral imperative with the stated goal of
the 1948 Taft housing legislation being
a decent home for every American family
coffin was also ashamed that and i'm
quoting him I've listened to many a
Marxist accuse the churches of having a
vested interest in unjust structures
that produce victims to whom good
Christians can then pour out their
hearts in charity I've listened and I've
shuddered because so often in history
it's been so true bill coffin was a true
prophet a modern-day Isaiah challenging
the church as much as he did government
leaders and business people had i but
one wish
the churches of America he said I think
it would be that they come to see the
difference between charity and justice
charity is a matter of personal
attributes justice a matter of public
policy charity seeks to alleviate the
effects of injustice justice seeks to
eliminate the causes of it charity in no
way affects the status quo while justice
leads inevitably to political
confrontation he get down to both
trickle-down economics and the idea that
faith-based social services are enough
demanding in the words of the Prophet
Amos let justice roll down like waters
and righteousness like an ever-flowing
stream now obviously we're in much more
difficult economic times over the last
year than we've been for certainly any
time in my lifetime and homelessness has
increased and it's more entrenched than
ever was particularly struck by this in
a trip that I took to Chicago just last
weekend although we have plenty of
homeless people in Palo Alto California
as well not long ago we opened an
opportunity center near the Stanford
campus to provide resources and housing
to this population we reading the book
of Acts that the early Christian
communities in in the early Christian
communities none were needy because they
would sell their possessions and goods
and distribute the proceeds to all as
any had need but the societal answer now
well beyond voluntary giving and mutual
support in Christian communities is
legislation that covers each and every
citizen equally as a matter of social
justice of course there should be
universal health care in America as
there is in virtually ever every other
industrialized country in the world
there should be protection for
homeowners who received subprime
mortgage mortgage loans in good faith
and there should be continued extension
of unemployment benefits for those who
have been laid off during this time but
importantly in terms of what I'm saying
today we created the homelessness crisis
in America by a series of political
decisions in the 1980s and we can end it
today by political decisions that we can
make from a religious perspective we
have to understand that we're all in
this together what the Apostle Paul says
of the body of Christ that is the church
we must now say of the whole world the
body does not consist of one member but
many the I cannot say to the hand I have
no need of you nor again to the head to
the feet I have no need of you if one
member suffers all suffer together with
it if one member is honored all rejoice
together in it times like this we must
remember how deeply interlocked and
interdependent we are we need to develop
the ability to talk to one another
across all divisions of age and
occupation and ethnicity and class about
our common plight and our vision of
solutions for the common good and that
should happen in grocery stores and on
the streets and in our neighborhoods on
the playing fields of subway in school
wherever people gather outside of our
normal insularity how ironic then that
words like class warfare we utilize
during the 2008 presidential campaign
after the economic crisis began with
predictably divisive effect and how many
times that we heard our current
president condemned as a socialist
Christianity in this age must remind us
of the truth of Jesus's words that we
cannot serve both God and wealth money
or the fantasy of economic security may
always stand as the greatest temptation
to violate the fur
of the Ten Commandments i am the lord
your god you shall have no other gods
before me you shall not make for
yourself an idol it's the golden calf
which we risk bowing down to and
worshipping every day ultimately what
matters most from a Christian
perspective is love and community
including a deep and abiding commitment
to social justice charity may provide
band-aids to the effect of poverty but
only justice seeks to eliminate its
causes charity as it's often been said
may lead people to pull a drowning baby
out of a river and pulling a second and
a third baby floating down behind it but
justice requires that we go upstream and
see why those babies are ending up in
the river in the first place and
eliminating the problem at its source
charity yes always bill coffin said from
this pulpit but never as a substitute
for justice what we keep forgetting in
this country is that people have basic
rights the right to food the right to
decent housing the right to medical care
the right to education close quote maybe
we recognize the love which is our
birthright and our calling may we take
joy in human caring and recognizing the
kinship that we all share and then we
move beyond mere charity to a commitment
to justice in the words the apostle
Michael what does the Lord require of
you but to do justice and to love
kindness and to walk humbly with our God
amen